donc j'entre sur la route de glace je dois
enlever mes ceintures de sécurité c'est
probablement la seule route au Canada où
vous n'êtes pas autorisé à porter certaines
ceintures de sécurité c'est beaucoup plus sûr au cas où
quelque chose se passe sur la route pour ne pas être
portez vos ceintures de sécurité ouais c'est le
début de la route de glace qui vient juste de
sortir du sentier Ingraham et comme vous pouvez le
voir, c'est assez large, nous aurons un
peu de terrain ici et puis à un moment donné
j'entrerai dans le grand lac
donc c'est un lac Tibbett comme vous pouvez le voir
là-bas la limite de vitesse pour les camions est de 25
kilomètres à l'heure je conduis une
camionnette donc je peux aller un peu plus vite mais je
vais rester dans cette voie
c'est le marqueur de kilomètre de santé
c'est pour aider les camions à garder notre
distance alpha-kilométrique et c'est ce qu'ils
font ils doivent voyager en convois d'au
moins deux à quatre et ils doivent garder
une distance de 500 mètres les uns des autres
pour des raisons de sécurité ainsi et pour empêcher
le  la glace de se briser sous eux,
je vois que la ceinture veut  pour être entièrement
armé, je vais devoir gérer cela pendant
les deux prochaines heures pendant que je suis dans
les airs, ma vitesse est actuellement de 40
kilomètres à l'heure
imaginez que les chauffeurs de camion ne peuvent pas
aller plus vite que 25 kilomètres à l'heure
vous  peut voir les fissures de glace et
apparemment c'est une bonne chose car cela
me permet
donc c'est un problème La région du lac
c'est une zone où je suppose que la glace n'est pas
très bonne et c'est pourquoi tout le trafic
doit réduire la vitesse et comme vous pouvez le voir
plus loin dans  ici la limite de vitesse sur ce
lac est de 15 kilomètres à l'heure pour
le système de circulation